hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the main character types that sir
and Kierkegaard talks about in fear and
trembling bringing it up in the section
that he calls the preliminary
expectoration
is what he terms the night of faith
night in a chivalric sense but as I
pointed out elsewhere let's not take
this as a solely male thing because it's
equally possible for anybody of whatever
gender to be a night of faith in the way
that Kierkegaard is talking about here
and he counter poses it to another key
figure who's expressing in some respects
what is best in human beings called the
night of infinite resignation but the
night of faith goes beyond the night of
infinite resignation as a matter of fact
the way that Kierkegaard arranges them
in relation to each other as he says
that before you can actually be the
night of faith in some way you have to
go on through Infinite resignation as a
sort of stage and this can be associated
with the three stages that Kierkegaard
talks about in other works the aesthetic
where one is concerned primarily with
just things in the world and sort of
scattered among them not even aware of
the need to fundamentally prioritize
among them and make important sacrifices
then the realm of the ethical where one
becomes aware of the you might say
infinite depths of what it is that the
spiritual or mental or whatever you want
to call it realm offers to us as
distinctively human this is a realm of
the universal where what goes for me can
equally go for you and I want to be able
to communicate my insights to you and
then there's a higher realm that of the
religious and the night of faith as you
can well surmise is going to be moving
within this realm of the religious
Kierkegaard is not using these
categories very heavily here but that's
some of the underpinnings of it
Knight of infinite resignation is moving
within the realm of the the ethical so
the knight of faith has as he says
resigned everything infinitely and then
grasp everything again and this is a
term that he's going to use over and
over again in this section by virtue of
the absurd by virtue of the absurd means
not that of the absurd is somehow a
virtue but through the means of the
absurd or by the power that the absurd
offers or the possibilities that the
absurd brings to bear for us even in
seeming impossibility and we'll talk
about that in just a moment
so the the knight of infinite
resignation and the knight of faith are
connected with each other in some some
very important ways he actually says
infinite resignation is the last stage
before faith so anyone who has not made
this movement does not have faith and I
think that's very useful for recognizing
that Kierkegaard is talking about
something quite different than many
people believe understand or believe
when they talk about faith there's a
common conception that faith is sort of
like knowledge or a substitute for it
that would be accessible through some
sort of religious revelation or object
and it's it's just not as good as
knowledge because it can't be explained
so it's a kind of credence and in things
without actually possessing genuine
knowledge but it operates as sort of a
facsimile or substitute for knowledge
Kierkegaard says that's not what faith
is at all so he tells us that why is
this important in infinite resignation I
become conscious of my eternal validity
and only then can one speak of grasping
existence by means of faith so this
gives us another conception of what this
grasping things by the virtue of the
absurd actually means he also tells us
too that
cuz resignation is antecedent because it
precedes the movement of faith in this
case faith he says is no aesthetic
emotion but something far higher it's
not the spontaneous inclination of the
heart but the paradox of existence so
that is very important faith is not
something that you begin from it's
something that you arrive at the night
of faith is somebody who has had to
either if not being a night of infinite
resignation at least pass through
infinite resignation and then they
become able to transcend to move to
something higher this is a good place to
talk about the metaphor of the ballet
dancer that Kierkegaard uses he tells us
that many people are not at this point
suited for it although this is this is
possible for anybody that they just sort
of remain on the surface of life ballet
dancers leap they come up and they go
down and he wants to use this as a
metaphor for leaping into the infinite
and then coming back down and planting
in a position and he tells us that the
night of faith is able to do this in a
way that the night of infinite
resignation is not actually able to pull
off he says that the night of here we go
most people live completely absorbed in
worldly joys and sorrows their
Benchwarmers who don't take part in the
dance so put them aside for the moment
the nights of infinity are ballet
dancers they have elevation they make
the upward movement and come down again
but every time that they do they're
unable to assume the posture whatever it
happens to be immediately there's a
little wobbling there's an oscillation
there they don't quite fit into
existence the night of faith however
does he tells us that the night of faith
down in such a way that there is no
dissonance there is no slight
contradiction he says that they can come
down and assume the position immediately
and what is he talking about there two
of the categories that he's using are
the infinite and finitude finitude is
the world that we experience with its
limits with its conditions and the night
of faith slips perfectly into this
finite world they are at ease in it they
are comfortable in it even though they
go beyond it at every moment again by
virtue of the absurd so there's this
movement from the finite to the infinite
to the finite once again and he talks
about the night of faith as somebody who
essentially swims within the finite and
as is aoki with it so there are some
other things that he talks about here
but I think I want to jump ahead to his
characterization of the night of faith
he tells us I honestly confess in my
experience I have not found a single
authentic instance although I do not
deny that every second person may be
such an example of the night of faith I
travel around and I look for them and he
says a person like this might be easily
mistaken for the bourgeois Philistine
and now that's a term that we don't
typically use these days Philistine ISM
what it means is somebody who you know
partakes in the higher culture but
doesn't appreciate the higher culture
there the person who goes and watches
the art movie and puts their feet up and
gets out in the middle to go to the
bathroom or get some popcorn and comes
back and says what did I miss
and the night of faith could be somebody
like that they could be really anybody
because you'd never actually recognize
them the way you can the night of
infinite resin
nation he says the night of infinite
resignation is easy to recognize their
walk is light and bold there's that
slight wobbling as they come back to the
the finite showing that they're not
entirely comfortable in this world that
doesn't entirely work for them but that
they nevertheless maintain their love
their desire both in its in his
uniqueness and in his hereit says in its
energy and youth the night of faith fits
in better and so it's easy to imagine
them as he does as some guy who you're
walking along with and start a
conversation with he says sunday is for
him a holiday he goes to church no
heavenly gaze or any sign of the
incommensurable betrays him if one did
not know him it would be impossible to
distinguish him from the rest of the
crowd in the afternoon he takes a walk
to the woods he enjoys everything he
sees the swarms of people the new
omnibus is the sound encountering him
one would take him for a mercantile soul
enjoying himself he finds pleasure in
this way for he's not a poet
and noticed that the night of faith in
this case he's describing him in a way
that doesn't make him this pious monkish
soul just you know doing his religious
duty or something like that he enjoys
the world the created world because he
sees it in relation to God he doesn't
have to be constantly bringing up how he
has faith or Jesus saved him or
something along those lines he's able to
appreciate for example being stuck in a
line or making a dish he has a great
example here of this guy walking along
and telling his interlocutor about the
wonderful dish that his wife has
prepared for him at home and he gets
there
there's no dish prepared and it doesn't
bother him at all because he is ok with
existence he is still getting
what he needs out of existence by virtue
of the absurd so here's a good place to
talk about some of the things that the
absurd isn't that Kierkegaard wants to
stress to us he tells us the absurd does
not belong to the differences that lie
within the proper domain of the
understanding and he singles out three
things where we could easily get mixed
up having faith in the absurd or having
faith by virtue of the absurd is not the
same thing as believing what is
improbable like I'm going to win the
lottery now it's impossible for me
because I don't actually play the
lottery but if I go and buy a ticket it
is incredibly improbable that I'm going
to win the lottery but I could believe
in it nonetheless and if I happen to get
the winning ticket that's not absurd
it's just unlikely absurd is when it's
not probable because it's not even
possible
I didn't play the lottery and somehow I
wound up a winner
that's something absurd it's not the
same thing it's something unexpected
either you know you go on a date with
somebody who was set you were set up
with and the people who set you up have
you know these things to say about the
person and you're thinking oh this is
going to be terrible and it turns out to
be a wonderful you know evening well
that's not the absurd heat there right
that's just unexpected or biting into a
candy bar and it's you know the same one
that you've had every lunch break and
suddenly it turns out that it's filled
with whatever your favorite filling is
that you couldn't get before well I get
unexpected but not not impossible and
it's not something that's unforeseen
either I mean if you think about how
much we're actually able to foresee it's
pretty limited unforeseen things happen
to us all the time even things that we
ought to be able to foresee if we have
the time or energy to put some thought
into it there unforeseen for us the
absurd is not that so what is the absurd
the absurd is the
possible that does however get made
possible and he tells us the moment that
the night executed the act of
resignation he was convinced of the
impossibility humanly speaking that was
a conclusion of the understanding he had
sufficient energy to think it and the
night of infinite resignation lingers
with that and they're not okay with it
in one sense but they become okay with
it in another sense the night of faith
goes further and says it is still
possible it will turn out my way God
will fulfill God's promises well however
paradoxical they may seem so he goes on
he says to the understanding that's
having is no absurdity right giving it
up the night of faith realizes this just
as clearly consequently he can be saved
only by the absurd this he grasps and
faith so he acknowledges the
impossibility and at the very same
moment he believes the absurd for if he
wants to believe he has faith without
passionately acknowledging the
impossibility with his whole heart and
soul he's deceiving himself we have
faith in the things that we have to have
faith in because only faith would
actually suffice there if it's having
faith and then the faith being fulfilled
later on that's not faith as Kierkegaard
is talking about it if it was reasonably
fulfilled if if it was well I have faith
in this murder mystery novel that will
get to the bottom of the story and it'll
be the butler and it turns out to be the
butler that's not faith in the sense
that Kierkegaard talks about here
there's two other things that he wants
to distinguish as well he says that
faith is a passion but it's not the same
passion as what he calls irony or humor
and Kierkegaard is definitely somebody
who's very interested in both irony and
humor he wrote an entire work on irony
so he says that
there's a lot of talk these days about
irony and humor especially by people
have never been able to practice or them
but know how to explain everything I
know that these two passions are
essentially different from the passion
of faith how are they different he gives
us an explanation irony and humor are
also self-reflective and belonged to the
sphere of infinite resignation their
elasticity is owing to the individuals
in commencer ability with actuality so
this leads us back then to this this
this question well what about the night
of faith what is so distinctive about
him why or her why is this so important
he tells us that this is a little bit
earlier with the freedom from care of a
reckless good-for-nothing he lets things
take care of themselves and yet at every
moment of his life he buys the
opportunity time at the highest price
because he does not do even the
slightest thing except by virtue of the
absurd he says he drains the deep
sadness of life and infinite resignation
he knows the blessedness of infinity he
has felt the pain of renouncing
everything the most precious thing in
the world and yet this is a key idea the
finite tastes just as good to him as to
one who never knew anything higher
because his remaining infinitude would
have no trace of a timorous anxious
routine and yet he has the security that
makes him delight in it as if finitude
was the surest thing of all and yet the
whole earthly figure he presents is a
new creation by virtue of the absurd he
resigned everything infinitely and then
he grasped everything again by virtue of
the absurd we come back to the passage
that we began with
and hopefully this gives you some
conception of what Kierkegaard is
talking about here with this this
character of the night of faith and now
if we apply this to Abraham is Abraham
himself
off a night of faith or is he something
beyond that or is he perhaps the first
night of faith that's something that you
should try to ponder and think about
what we know about the Abraham's story
and about what the absurd would be in
that case the answer is of course in the
texts but I leave it to you to find it
there
you